foreign
everybody it is October 3rd 2022 I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report we
are live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
Blaze TV subscribe if you have not uh
today's show is going to be a little bit
different than usual uh we obviously are
going to cover some of what's going on
uh here in Florida because the disaster
we're just seeing more and more video
and uh even though the hurricane itself
is now over really the the cleanup and
fixing this thing has just begun and uh
you all know how appreciative I am of my
new state and I am going to do
everything possible I kept thinking
about it all weekend like I feel like in
some ways I have like a new mission in
life which is to now really uh help my
state I think I sort of had that mission
in a broad sense like when it comes to
freedom and all that kind of stuff and
and helping the governor and all that
but now I feel this other thing about
trying to rebuild the state
um so we're going to talk a bit about
what's going on right now in Florida uh
and then in about 10 10 minutes or so
former Congressman he's the former
congressman from the Fort Myers Sanibel
Captiva area Trey radel he's a buddy of
mine we met a couple years ago he's down
in Fort Myers Fort Myers Beach right now
we're going to Skype him in and he can
give an update uh really on the ground
of what's going on and it's it's it's
pretty bad I mean this this state is
hurting right now as I said we're going
to work on doing some fundraisers and
and a whole bunch more because Florida
needs some help and then of course
because politics infects absolutely
everything if you did not see it on
Friday vice president Kamala Harris gave
one of the most disgusting racist
remarks I have ever heard a politician
give like in in their Wildest Dreams
Trump never said anything really as
racist and awful as what Kamala said
regarding how they were going to help
people in Florida related to equity and
how they would help communities of color
first while she's getting major blow
back on that thankfully because the clip
went viral and everyone's calling her
out for it and by the way it's against
the Constitution to help people based on
the color of their skin we used to call
that racist so I'm going to go off on
Kamala Harris I'm giving you a
pre-warning on that one and then we're
going to show you a bunch of Clips
actually of uh of good things that are
happening down here and obviously our
competent Governor but the entire
apparatus doing the best that they can a
couple other ancillary political things
and uh and there we go oh and by the way
on a on a totally good note
um baby two uh is coming on Thursday we
are inducing unless unless maybe two
shows up in the next two or three days
baby two is coming on Thursday so uh
life continues I guess it's a it's a
weird it's a weird time uh anyway let's
talk about my Patriot Supply and then
we'll get to everything guys are you
prepared for the coming food shortages
that farmers keep warning us about if
not go to prepare with reuben.com and
you'll save 20 on a three-month
emergency food kit from my Patriot
Supply they're the nation's largest
preparedness company with millions of
satisfied customers right now they're
offering this rare 20 discount on
emergency food to help everyone get
prepared for what's coming go to prepare
with reuben.com to get your three-month
emergency food kit that's packed with a
wide variety of delicious meals
breakfast lunch dinner drinks snacks you
won't go hungry when you have this kit
on hand to avoid fights be sure to get
one kit for each member of your family
at this price you can afford to feed
everybody even cousin Irving these three
month kits are in stock and ship fast
with free delivery your order will rely
arrive discreetly in unmarked boxes for
your privacy don't wait the sale and
soon go to prepare with reuben.com
prepare with reuben.com and now back to
me okay so let's get
to a little bit of what's working in
Florida right now because there's
obviously a humanitarian disaster we
know about some loss of life and we'll
probably find out more uh there are
roads and bridges that are destroyed
houses that are gone communities that
are wiped out I mean this was this was a
truly as Governor DeSantis called it
this was a Biblical storm uh so first
right now Elon Musk has jumped in we've
got a tweet from the New York Post Elon
is helping Ron DeSantis working with
Elon musk's starlink to restore internet
in areas battered by Hurricane and
obviously people want to be able to
communicate with family members and I
have a couple friends that were on
Sanibel that we couldn't get in touch
with finally did in the last day or two
people seem to be okay but here's
Governor DeSantis talking about his
collaboration with Elon Musk we also
work working we're working with Elon
Musk and starlink satellite so they're
positioning those star lights uh the
starlink satellites to provide good
coverage in Southwest Florida and other
affected areas we have with me where do
I have the uh do I have it so here are
the star links that we're going to
provide for Lee County and so what this
will do so they have satellites that
beam down but you can't just get it on
your device without having things like
that beaming it to the public or being
whatever so those are going to be really
for their use at the places that are
offering the emergency response so that
they can be fully hooked up and can get
online if they need to go at the same
time we are working with SpaceX and we
are expecting 120 additional large
starlink units to deploy to Southwest
Florida and so they've donated the costs
associated with all the coverage so we
want to thank SpaceX and thanks thank
Elon Musk for that okay you know I kept
thinking as I was watching clips of the
governor all weekend you know I was in
New York during 9 11 and one of the
things that I think kept people going
kept people focused allowed the workers
to do their job allowed people to have
hope was that Rudy Giuliani was
absolutely incredible it was obvious I'm
the mayor of this city I'm in charge of
the services the buck stops with me and
that clearly is what's happening with
DeSantis right now it goes without
saying the guy's done a great job with
covid and everything else the state the
State of the State is strong but right
now he's he's really shining and it's
not really about him the fact that he
knows all of this stuff like they've got
the satellites up there we've got to get
these down here huge swaths of Southwest
Florida Fort Myers area do not Naples
area do not have power right now they
certainly don't have internet so this is
a way that people can get in touch with
friends and family members and
everything else actually I mentioned
we're bringing on former congressman and
radio host Tre iridel in a few minutes
he's in an area of Fort Myers I think he
said it was 2 percent of the area has
internet he somehow got to a place with
some with some internet one of the
incredible things that's also happening
is that the administration is going all
over the state and they're making sure
that wherever the governor shows up
they're not stopping helping people in
the middle of all of this reporter asked
Governor DeSantis about that
[Music]
purchase for you you've refusal
operations deceased while you come into
town around the state can you tell us
about the Pod program oh yeah no
everything goes I mean like they said
Don't Stop anything we want to do I
think on these pods you know this is a
symptom of success there's a rush people
get it and then it does die down so when
we were just across the river it was
open but there was no one that was
needing it at that time and I think it's
because they've done a good job of
getting this stuff out I just thought it
was worth showing that just to show the
guys on the ground he's making sure that
wherever he goes obviously there's going
to be a lot of fanfare around him but
he's making sure that these pods they
drop these pods off they have all sorts
of emergency relief supplies that people
are still going to be able to get to it
that none of the emergency work stops
just because you know the the celebrity
Governor is in town he's just out there
doing absolutely everything he can and
then I just wanted to show you in case
some of you guys missed it on Friday we
did a last second interview with Casey
DeSantis obviously she's the first lady
and we put it up Friday afternoon so
obviously you know that's not prime time
for people to watch and figure out how
they can help so she was at the uh
coordination Center basically in
Tallahassee which is the capital of the
state uh and she talked a bit about how
you can help there is still a mission
going on to rescue folks and we have the
National Guard we have the Coast Guard
we have our First Responders law
enforcement who are going around in
those affected areas and Fort Myers
Beach and Sanibel Island and some of the
barrier islands and they're going into
making sure that people are okay but
what you can do is go to
volunteerflorida.org once you get there
there's something called volunteer
connect that is a portal that we are
using as a path through pass through to
the non-profits that are again on the
ground on the front lines and they are
looking for support so the American Red
Cross is looking for boots on the ground
because right now we have 600 trucks
some are already there some are on their
way from places like Louisiana we have a
lot of resources that we have been
staying aging here in the State of
Florida we're getting them to those
distribution points in Florida and then
we're going to need folks in addition to
the folks that are already there to
distribute things like water bottles and
food and blankets and tarps that we have
and so that is a really great way
volunteerflorida.org to figure out how
you can help firsthand if you want to be
on the ground and frankly there's some
other ways that you can donate your time
not necessarily being there in Southwest
Florida
okay so if you want to watch the full
thing it's about a 10 or 12 minute
interview we did it really on the Fly
just so we could get some information
out it's up on YouTube and Rumble and on
blaze of course and as uh the first lady
said there at the end it's not that you
can just donate money you can donate
resources and time and services and all
sorts of stuff and I just thought it was
worth repeating because we've got good
people that are coordinating all of this
stuff there's been no looting here in
Florida I mean everything is working to
its to its best ability so now I want to
bring in uh former congressman and
current radio host although he's his
radio station was destroyed uh Trey
radel he is in Fort Myers right now and
Trey are you there
I am I've got you Trey it's uh it's good
to see you you know we became friends a
couple years back because I I love
Southwest Florida and I've been going to
Sanibel my entire life I never you know
this I never once talked about Sanibel
publicly nor would even be photographed
with the hat because I loved it so much
I didn't want anyone to know about it it
was just this this wonderful secret
place magical place uh you are the
former congressman from Fort Myers area
so first could you just give 30 seconds
on your connection to the to the area
what you've done there what you're doing
now and then we'll talk about the storm
and everything else sure so uh
but 20 years ago I moved here uh as a
young man in my 20s and I was a reporter
with the local CBS News affiliate uh I
uh I covered more hurricanes than I can
count uh and and all of the regular news
working as a reporter and anchor uh I
served here uh as uh the U.S congressman
and I currently have a radio show on the
local Fox affiliate which happens to be
housed in that same building with that
CBS affiliate so those people are like
family to me we've all worked together
for almost 20 years and uh and that the
local CBS affiliate all of our radio
stations owned by that company uh uh
that building is is gone and we're all
fair so you are offside right now but
you're in one little area somewhere at
Fort Myers where there there is power
right because the whole area basically
has no power at the moment
uh so power has been coming on gradually
I don't know what percentage we're at
now last I heard uh it was maybe 60
percent of Lee County the county that
I'm in in uh in Fort Myers uh was
without power and I I'm I'm lucky man
you know I've got a kids and I'm I'm in
in my office of my home where which is
currently also my bedroom because we've
got so many people staying with us and
uh and I I feel so lucky I feel guilty
quite frankly
uh learning what I've learned over the
past couple of days I'm going to have
Connor just throw in some b-roll as
we're talking about some of the
devastation in the area
um I don't know if you're able to see
some of this stuff on on your end uh but
we'll do it yeah I mean the storm
surgeon just I mean just basically just
tell me about the area what what can we
do to help and you know what the people
are like and all the stuff
sure uh to speak to this video that is
storm surge and that is the most
dangerous component of this that I
believe on Fort Myers Beach you're
looking at that hitting about 10 to 12
feet of storm surge on that on that
video
uh and um and it was wiped out see
here's the situation you have the
hurricane itself
um the hurricane
just didn't move it parked over
Southwest Florida and just battered the
hell out of this area and what you see
on the news is horrific Sanibel and Fort
Myers Beach it's going to take
years and years to rebuild they're
basically gone they are at this point
uninhabitable and that includes some of
the other Barrier Islands places like
Matt Lachey Pine Island and more
um but here's where it's insane man you
are if you're remotely familiar with the
state of Florida I want you to visualize
like the Miami Fort Lauderdale area and
if you shoot directly across the
Everglades that's where I'm going to
start that's Naples Marco Island and
Naples
that area had a terrible flooding in in
pockets all over Collier County where
Naples is located you then move north
and you get to North Naples you move
into Bonita Springs which is in South
Lee County then you eventually get into
the Fort Myers area Fort Myers Beach
Sanibel Cape Coral uh and and then you
keep moving further north into Charlotte
County which brings me to about the last
point of roughly the Port Charlotte area
in Northern Charlotte County and and
what I'm talking about here to
illustrate the severity of the damage
aside from what you're seeing in the
national news on Fort Myers Beach in
Sanibel is you have in every single one
of these counties hundreds and hundreds
of pockets which include thousands of
homes that were all flooded let me give
that in the timeline now so basically if
you were to drive from this East Naples
area which which sustained tons of
flooding up to that Northern Charlotte
area area you're looking at a roughly
two hour drive so two hours door to door
and you're talking an innumerable amount
of neighborhoods with you know hundreds
of homes in every pocket that are all
flooded out what this means in terms of
of the insurance companies
whether or not anyone can sustain this
it has yet to be seen uh because the
damage is so massive and widespread and
by the way it's it's worth mentioning
you know there was a meme online somehow
that Southwest Florida is filled only
with rich people because people think of
Naples or the islands there are plenty
of trailer park communities there there
are blue collar workers all over the
place and it's also irrelevant to how
much money someone has when disaster
comes I want to put up some some b-roll
of the the Sanibel Causeway I mean the
road this is the road that connects Fort
Myers to Sanibel it jumps across these
tiny little islands that are there it's
it's complete we gone I mean that's
going to take forever to rebuild
yes and and what that means is is
Sanibel the only way to access it uh is
by helicopter or boat
uh and that and so where I'm at in Fort
Myers it's one of the most disturbing
things post hurricane that I see by the
hour uh I can watch Coast Guard
helicopters fly their different paths
that are going from what my standpoint
directly overhead heading west to
Sanibel and then I can also see them
shooting Southwest over to Fort Myers
Beach and every Chopper that I see means
another several people getting rescued
off the island that have been there now
for days what's insane about this
Causeway if people are seeing this right
now is that this thing was built was you
know they had an original Causeway that
was old and then they built this what
maybe 15 years ago so this thing is
pretty new like this is not some old
rickety bridge that was just taken out
man I love this island so much to go
back to my experience I actually slept I
was a reporter with the local CDs
affiliate I talked about I slept on
Sanibel Island that night to do live
news reports that evening and that
morning when that bridge was built
because that was the last time that
Sanibel had no access with the exception
of air and water was when they built
that Causeway and I was on Sanibel that
night can you talk can you just talk a
little bit about well I want to talk
about how people can help but before
that just like in terms of the services
that are in Fort Myers right now I mean
you know what's going on was were people
prepared enough what do you want if if
we can get this message to DeSantis it's
like what do you want him to do what do
you want the state to do
yeah
you know uh DeSantis Iran uh who is a a
friend I was sworn into congress with
him and I've known him for a long time
I'm so happy that that man is in charge
of our state right now we are in great
hands
um you know look I think that Casey
DeSantis the first lady of State really
said it best um you could go to
volunteerflorida.org uh and you know
there are ways that you contribute this
and that
um
what
what hot look man sorry I I'm not my
daughter is moving faster right now
like right now uh people are dying post
storm yeah uh because with no
electricity which you know Iran has been
leaning on the coast
lcec these are some of our local
companies FPL which people may have
heard of
fpl's done a hell of a job uh Ron called
out lcec to try to get Cape Coral back
online we need electricity uh uh to get
people just kind of back to a semblance
of of a routine and their mental health
there have been more people uh Baker
acted in the last 72 hours than probably
the past two years and what that is is
people unwillingly going to be put into
hospitals mental health facilities at
least nine people have died putting
generators too close to their damn homes
and that again is because of lack of
electricity so I know that it's being
worked on but anytime you go through
these it's frustrating after Irma here
at my place where I'm at now we were out
for about five days we had no
electricity
um and and next uh the water is going to
be an issue you cannot use your water
unless it's being boiled or you've got
bottled water but everything that I
understand Governor DeSantis has really
done a hell of a job in leading with the
local County Commissioners throughout
Southwest Florida to make sure that Red
Cross in particular set up food and
water distribution points for people
so you know it's awful it's the damage I
cannot stress enough is incomprehensible
on it on an economic level and then that
personal level that we're talking about
right now uh and if there's any Silver
Lining I will say as someone who is
critical as hell of government of state
and local elected officials uh they've
done a hell of a job well Trey I promise
you that uh I'm not going to forget
about you my audience is not going to
forget about Fort Myers and Sanibel and
the whole area I'm going to come down
there as soon as I can we got a baby
coming this week and then I'll be I'll
be down there and raising funds and
doing whatever I can do and uh I'll just
keep amplifying the message for you man
and we wish you guys the best thank you
if there's anything I can do to help
with that man I'm all yours I really
appreciate you allowing me to share this
story uh uh with so many uh of your
amazing uh and your amazing audience who
I know we're all like-minded in many
ways congrats on the baby man I I um I
again feel guilty I'm so blessed that
I'm here my kids and I and and wife all
made it out safe all right well next
time we speak hopefully things will be a
little more settled uh all right thank
you Trey
thank you all right guys I mean look
this this thing is going to be rough and
I know maybe it's not the most uh fun
thing to be talking about and maybe not
necessarily why you're normally tuning
in to hear me talk about the news and
make silly comments about the wilkesters
and all that stuff but I hope you'll
bear with us through through a little
bit of this but now let's get to the
political part of it uh because of
course everything is political and
although at the state level everything
has been done
unbelievably well here as Trey just
mentioned I mean the state is
functioning really well uh from from the
governor on down you know we're getting
the electric connected we're getting
starlink like we're helping people
they're still rescuing people I mean
it's it's it's a massive undertaking uh
but that that
massive undertaking that's working well
here is in stark contrast to uh what's
going on with the federal government
surprise surprise video came out on
Friday of Kamala Harris the vice
president again a woman who was polling
at zero in her own party when the people
behind Biden picked her to be the vice
president uh talked about giving
resources based on Equity I I saw this
video on Friday night I cannot tell you
how absolutely enraged I was when I saw
this take a look
it is our lowest income communities and
our communities of color that are most
impacted by these extreme conditions and
and impacted by by issues that are not
of their own making and so we
absolutely and so we have to address
this in a way that is about giving
resources based on Equity understanding
that we we fight for equality but we
also need to fight for Equity
understanding not everyone starts out at
the same place and if we want people to
be in an equal Place sometimes we have
to take into account those disparities
look Kamala Harris is is racist she
she's racist she is not bright
um she's pretending to be vice president
I mean I get I get it it says it on on
the placard on her desk but this woman
is an absolute clown and and what she
said right there is completely the
antithesis of the American ethos we have
equality not Equity it does not matter
that we do not all start at the same
place some people are really are born
really rich and with all the skills in
the world some people are born poor with
no skills some people have great
physical attributes some people are
somewhere in between bad things happen
to good people all of those things
America is the promise of opportunity
the idea that the vice president of the
United States during one of the biggest
hurricanes to ever hit an American state
would say that we will give resources
based on Equity to communities of color
you know it's this when I said to Trey
before that there's this meme out there
that this whole area Southwest Florida
because the beaches are so and I said
it's all these rich people first off if
a rich person losing their house is as
unfortunate and sad and disastrous as a
poor person losing their house now we
can talk about how the government should
come in and maybe it needs to put some
more resources to people who need it but
not based on skin color it's absolutely
disgusting it's anti-American and and
truly if they were able to put that into
play if the federal government was able
to put resources to help communities of
color more than communities of non-color
it would be against the Constitution of
the United States and if they try to do
it I hope that they'll impeach the the
old buffoon that she works for and and
get rid of her too these people are just
absolutely awful so when you
when your friends are saying to you oh
the woke stuff isn't so bad and all this
race stuff isn't so bad of the gender
stuff isn't so bad you see how it's
connected to to the very Machinery that
then is supposed to help people in times
of Crisis uh you know when on Sanibel
right when you get onto the island you
take a right off the causeway onto
Periwinkle Drive the main road over
there and there's a big community of
mobile homes you think these are rich
people I don't know what color they are
I've never thought about it never
thought about it I've been there because
they they used to have a little uh a
little petting zoo and some birds and
some things so I used to take my nieces
and nephews over there never once
thought about the color of the people
but it this is this is the vile toxic
ideas of the left that have permeated
government to the highest possible
levels that this woman dare think that
it is okay to look at a disaster area
and say we'll give more money to black
people than we will white people it is
racism pure and simple it's not Reverse
Racism them it's racism and she is
racist and she's a clown and she knows
she's a clown because she's even
laughing as she says it because yes we
have equality in the United States
Equity go go go to Venezuela
anyway a reporter tried to get her to
clarify her question or clarify her
comments uh yesterday
[Music]
nah fancy party fancy dress can't
clarify those remarks uh but actually
they are
anti-constitutional they are
unconstitutional you cannot do that
again because we have the promise of
equality we have equal protection over
the law under the law we have individual
rights and even FEMA is now backtracking
here's a tweet from the hill a FEMA
administrator says agency will support
everybody after Republicans attack
Harris Equity remark now leave it leave
it up for just a sec this is just such a
perfect the hill is just a crap Factory
in general but so I just grabbed the
headline from them but you see even the
way they frame that this is what
mainstream media does with everything so
they got the the broad part of this
right that the FEMA administrator says
that the agency will support everybody
well okay that's good so they're not
going to do it based on Equity they're
going to do it based on helping people
that need help they're not going to do
it through the racist prism that the
Democrats see everything through but the
second lie there after Republicans
attack Harris equity Mark so who are the
real bad guys here it's the Republicans
who attacked her for being racist God
once you see through these things you
can you can actually
you can see clearly through everything
actually once you see the way the media
lies about everything the way the
Democrats lie everything about
everything the way the Machinery lies
about everything but it doesn't end it
does not end with these people they're
they're bizarre and and radical woke
rhetoric about hurricane Ian continues
because of course they're going to
combine it with climate change and
immigration and a whole bunch more uh
here's noted alcoholic Congresswoman
Nancy Pelosi uh talking about the
hurricane and immigrants and why we need
these people or something
we have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers and The Growers saying
why are you shipping these uh
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops down here
okay first off back in the day or if say
yesterday a republican said that that we
need these people here to pick crops
they'd be called racist when they do it
of course she's not racist also they're
not immigrants Nancy they are illegal
immigrants if you were shipping the
legal people from state to state against
their will that would be a problem and
I'd be siding with you but these are
illegal immigrants who come to our
country because your elderly gentleman
pretending to be President Joe Biden
refuses to defend the Border also I have
not heard I am fairly well-versed in
Florida politics at this point I have
not heard anyone any crop grower or
orange Orchard Guy saying that we needed
those 50 people that we sent to Martha's
Vineyard so that they could pick their
crops but you see the way they view
these people she doesn't even view these
people as human she is the one who have
used these people as people they should
just be here to pick our crops we need
them to pick our crops but of course
this continues on the clown Network
known as MSNBC another racist these
people are they're racist and they
should just be called racists Joy Reed
she is trying to combine the Florida
evacuation to the fact that the Santa
sent these migrants out it's a little
confusing try to bear with her and be
careful about attacking people who have
to move to save their own lives and
safety because you never know when it's
your people that have to move when it's
your people who have to migrate when
it's your people who have to get on that
road
um so just just a thought
I stand by my statement last week that
Sunny Hosten is the worst person on
television but Joy Reed is pretty damn
close and if we did a scientific
qualitative comparison it is possible
that Joy Reid is worse than Sonny Hassan
but you see what they do there they
conflate all of these things that have
nothing to do with each other what she
wants you to do what she wants you to
think or what she wants her viewers to
think is that somehow DeSantis by
getting those 50 immigrants out of here
those 50 illegal immigrants I'll use the
verbiage properly who are not legally
here in the United States and sending
them to Martha's Vineyard even though he
had money in the budget to do it and the
Democrats of Florida did it that that
somehow is connected to people who had
to flee their houses because of a storm
a
god-controlled storm right an act of
nature that is is beyond any of our
abilities but they want you to be
confused about all these issues but what
do they really really want they really
want to connect this thing to climate
change and they if they really really
want anything else it's they want the
destruction I truly believe this they
want the destruction of Florida because
they believe that that would help take
out DeSantis and they think DeSantis is
well basically Trump on steroids uh
here's Joy Reid gloating about Florida
being hit by the hurricane
no shouldn't happen he Marco Rubio and
other tea party members as Senate and
House said they shouldn't have that
money it's too expensive and now as you
said he's now got to go hand in hand to
Joe Biden
for eight it's something he didn't even
believe in as a tea party
she is an absolute liar what Joy Reed is
referring to there is that Marco Rubio
and DeSantis and some other Republican
Senators years ago on another hurricane
voted against a bill because they wanted
the bill to just be straight up hey we
are going to give this money to help the
people but what happens in government
you guys all know this is all of this
port gets thrown in there all of this
extra money on all these pet projects so
that's what Ron DeSantis and Marco Rubio
were trying to fight they wanted to help
the people that were deserving which
hurricane was that for that was for
Hurricane Sandy they wanted all of the
money
to go to New York to go to the recovery
of Hurricane Sandy they didn't want the
pork involved but of course she doesn't
say that right because she's an absolute
liar and a fraud and that's what happens
when you work in mainstream media she
works at a massive fake News
disinformation Network known as MSNBC
Marco Rubio just commented on on this a
couple days ago here's from Yahoo news
Senator Marco Rubio on Sunday said he
would vote against a federal relief bill
to assist Florida in recovering from
Hurricane Ian if it contain unrelated
spending projects sure I will fight
against having pork in it that's the key
Rubio said on CNN State of the Union we
shouldn't have it in there because it
undermines the ability to come back and
do this in the future Rubio said that
extra spending would deter other
lawmakers from voting on it we can do it
it's possible to do it without loading
it with all these other things because
otherwise you have you will have people
in the senate in the house that are
going to vote against disaster relief
because they view these disaster relief
bills as ways for other people to get
their pork and pet projects done Rubio
said so that is exactly what Marco Rubio
and Ron DeSantis were talking about
during Hurricane Sandy Joy Reed is an
absolute liar and ever and this is why
everyone hates government why do people
hate government because they lie about
everything and then every time they
supposedly do something good like Hey
we're going to put federal funds to help
people who need it whether it's
Hurricane Sandy hitting New York whether
it's hurricane Ian hitting Florida you
find out oh there's I don't know let's
say 10 billion dollars to help these
people whatever the number is it's
irrelevant
but it turns out that they threw in an
extra 6 billion and some of that's going
to Ukraine and some of that's going here
and it's to you know study transgender
uh gerbils and and the rest of this
insane uh nonsense so Joy Reed is a liar
Marco Rubio is doing the right thing get
a clean bill and let's get those funds
there but let's continue with Joy Reid
racists
Dullard Joy read here she is blaming
hurricaneian on global warming
worse right I mean these things are
thriving because the water is getting
warmer and I think when people we
stopped calling it global warming for
political reasons that's what it is
right our Earth is getting warmer and
there is just no doubt I think left that
it is feeding these beasts
well and and what you where it comes out
is in the intensity the people say well
they've been hurricanes for Millennia
well that's true uh but we we sometimes
get these ones that are so much more
damaging and so much more intense okay
so they have no evidence of that they
have no evidence of that it's exactly
the same thing as Don Lemon on CNN
saying but when I was a kid hurricanes
didn't seem to be as scary you may
remember
two or three years ago there was
supposed to be a massive hurricane that
was going to hit Miami right and
everybody evacuated Miami and then it
hit and it wasn't that bad was that
because global warming isn't so scary
but they owe anytime something fits
their narrative they have the answer for
it uh the guy that she's talking to
there is Ali velshi and you may remember
Ali velshi during the summer of love as
there was a city I forget which city it
was maybe it was Kenosha was burning
down and there was buildings blowing up
in the background and there's huge fires
behind him and he kept calling them
mostly peaceful protesters it was one of
the great memes of 2020. it was Kenosha
so these people just lie about
everything she oh there's just no doubt
about it there's just no doubt about it
actually there is doubt about it there's
debate about it but that's why you guys
want to censor everybody and I'm
probably going to get kicked off of
YouTube for even saying it here's a
compilation of left-wing media Outlets
using Ian as an excuse to push climate
change hysteria scientists say climate
change could be fueling storms like
hurricane Ian storms like hurricane Ian
are only going to get stronger and more
dangerous as the climate crisis
progresses is there any doubt in your
mind that climate change is to blame the
power and deadly force of Ian in the
climate crisis tell us the impact of
climate change is producing more
frequent more extreme weather events you
know we get the whole climate change
angle of this too and it's increasing
with climate change climate change
looming in the background you know we
keep having these hurricanes coincidence
could be could be not hurricanes are
getting bigger and intensifying more
quickly yes climate change climate
change
intensifying hurricanes these storms are
intensifying these storms are
intensifying something is causing them
to intensify a phenomenon known as rapid
intensification rapid intensification
rapid intensification rapid
intensification rapid intensification
rapid intensification scientists say
that will become more common as the
Earth's oceans continue to warm climate
change is making storms like this one
stronger how do you attribute that to
climate change is that an effect of
climate change how does that dovetail
with climate change scientists have worn
this for a long time that storms won't
get necessarily more hurricanes out of a
climate change but the ones we do get
will be bigger and faster and wetter and
here is your exhibit a hurricane Ian
it's so again once you see through the
lies of the media and that the
everything is about narrative and
eventually they'll lock you in your
house because of climate change and
they'll want you eating bugs because of
climate change and they won't sacrifice
anything but they just want to scare the
F out of you like they did for two years
with covet and they don't want you to
question it too should you be allowed to
question it
I don't know I think so I think so I
don't think there's any evidence
I don't think there's any evidence just
because they keep saying it over and
over did they lie about everything for
two years related to covid here is un's
secretary for Global Communications
Melissa Fleming she's at the world
economic Forum Summit and uh yeah
apparently they own science and uh
they're gonna stifle the hell out of
everyone else
you know we partnered with Google for
example if you Google climate change
you will at the top of your search you
will get all kinds of un resources
we started this partnership when we were
shocked to see that when we'd Googled
climate change we were getting
incredibly distorted information right
at the top so we we're becoming much
more proactive um you know we own the
science and we think that the world you
know should know it and and the
platforms themselves also do
um but again it's it's it is um it's
it's a huge huge challenge that I think
all sectors of society need to be very
active in
we own the science that is what the
communications director at a world
economic Forum event just said we own
the science much like when fauci said if
you attack me you're attacking science
much like uh when Emperor Palpatine said
I am the Senate these are the bad guys
people know it know that they're lying
oh and then what do they do not only do
they own the science but then they work
with Google so that when you Google
something the information you get is not
say an open
an open series of articles based in fact
but they're what they want you to see
okay that is what they are doing and
they're doing it right in front of us so
that they can manipulate you however
however if you're watching this thing on
YouTube right now they can put
recommended videos to send you in a
completely other direction right when
you Google something they're telling you
hey we at the world economic Forum we
worked with Google to reorganize search
results all of it it's all right there
guys like putting the pieces together is
tough but it's all right there so let's
go full circle here because there are
liars like Joy Reed there are racists
like Kamala Harris there are Bad actors
like this woman from the world economic
forum and their giant tech companies
organizing all of this information to to
basically make you nothing other than
just some blob who will agree with
everything they say as they take away
all of your rights well
occasionally we do have leaders that
stand up against it this is absolutely
fantastic moment from yesterday as
Governor DeSantis again who is going
throughout the state on the ground
everywhere making sure everything works
the guys basically working 24 hours a
day as is the first lady but here's a
CNN reporter and what are they what does
she really want well she just really
really wants to get him but he ain't
having it how do you stand behind Lee
County's decision to not have that
mandatory evacuation until the day
before the storm well did you where was
your industry stationed when the storm
hit were you guys in Lee County no you
were in Tampa so that's you know they
were following the weather track and
they had to make decisions based on that
but you know 72 hours they weren't even
in the cone 48 hours they were on the
periphery so you got to make the
decisions the best you can I will say uh
you know they delivered the message to
people they had shelters open you know
everybody had adequate opportunity to at
least get to a shelter within the county
but you know a lot of the residents did
not um not want to do that I think for
probably for various reasons some people
just don't want to leave their home
period they're island people whatever
but I think part of it was so much
attention was paid to Tampa that I think
a lot of them probably thought that they
wouldn't get the worst of it so you know
they um but they did and I think it's uh
it's easy to second-guess them but they
were ready for the whole time and um and
made that call when when there was
justifiable to do so some of their
neighboring counties though did have
mandatory evacuations before Tuesday
well right but our neighboring I mean if
you look at like
um Tuesday morning they had moved the
track down model started showing it
going to like Sarasota you know so
that's that so so they did that I was in
Sarasota that day with them when they
were expanding some of their evacuations
you know Charlotte I think did the same
thing either Monday night or Tuesday
Morning
um so you know but don't forget Sunday
11 A.M advisory it was going to go to
Taylor County in North Florida
I think the guy knows what he's talking
about but you see what she wants to do
there she just wants to get him how come
you didn't evacuate earlier you may
remember at first this thing was going
to hit Miami right then they thought it
was going to go a little bit north
towards Sarasota as he said and hit tap
harder it ended up just kind of sitting
in Southwest Florida but they did
absolutely everything possible but the
media just wants one mix up they don't
care about the truth they care about
agenda whether that agenda is keeping
you afraid of climate change whether
that agenda is making you think that
it's right to help people during
Devastation based on the color of their
skin they just want more and more power
they are incompetent and they are not
good people and I I really believe that
the Silver Lining to this thing is first
off Florida will come through this thing
and I'm just telling you from being down
here the amount of people that are
trying to figure out how they can help
and will help and all that stuff it's
it's absolutely amazing I'm so proud to
be a Floridian because of it but I think
this could also be another bit of a red
pill moment that you know we always get
these little red pill moments but it's
getting very hard for the media to spin
this bad poorly on Florida and on
DeSantis not only do we prepare properly
but there he is in the entire
Administration out there doing
everything possible working with Elon
Musk and everything else but they wanted
it they want it bad so people see that
people see that BS and then they go well
wait a minute do I want to live in a
state that is run by you know say
competent people and you know when [ __ ]
hits the fan we're going to be taken
care of or do I just want the endless
destruction that they have everywhere
else I think the uh the choice is pretty
clear guys it's me Monday over at the
reubenreport.locals.com community here's
the one that I put up this morning
socialism mirrors prison free food Free
Shelter free clothes free education but
no freedom
with Albert Einstein right there a
couple comments from the locals
Community Joe says sunny and joy human
cartoons nothing wrong with cartoons
they have a place let's just recognize
what they are yeah it's kind of funny in
a way it's like they are just cartoon
characters that's what these that's what
mainstream media has done I mean think
about it when I mentioned that MSNBC so
it's part of NBC News Network like it's
a giant Corporation they know that Joy
Reed is lying about everything they know
her homophobic history they know her
racist history but they keep letting her
out there why is it that a giant
Corporation would want this
misinformation specialist on TV why is
it that they had mad out Rachel Maddow
uh on TV for years and years who was
lying about so much and lying about
covet and all of those things you think
that there's an end game there
you think X says I feel like they need
to get their story straight on illegal
immigration it's either that they are
wonderful people doctors lawyers
entrepreneurs Etc or we need them to
pick crops for us they can't have it
both ways I mean unfortunately because
of the media because of big Tech they
seemingly can have it both ways although
we we just have to wake up to it but yes
that's it's you're so right that that
Pelosi thing it's just so gross which he
says first off not making note that
these people are illegal they are not
immigrants if you just say they're
immigrants the implication is that they
are legally here they're supposed to be
here and then by the way if they were
legally here
and supposed to be here they should be
treated with equal protection under the
law and you shouldn't be able to just
boot them out of a state obviously but
they are illegally here in the first
place and but what should we have them
do we should have them pick our crops
but I you're right I thought they were
supposed to be doctors and lawyers and
all that stuff when Trump said that he
was racist when Pelosi says that it's
okay uh there's always that great quote
I think it's I think it was Reagan maybe
it's Churchill about if the left didn't
have double standards they'd have no
standards at all that's pretty much
where we're at uh Jeff says furthermore
the effort to control the starting line
is playing God who has ever played God
and come out okay well that's you know
that's also part of this thing it's like
things happen bad things happen to good
people there are there are events that
happen whether it is fires in California
whether it is earthquakes whether it is
hurricanes all of these things like we
live on a planet and mother nature is
bizarre and fickle and random and weird
and
you can do the best you can to hopefully
live in an area that you'll be as safe
as possible but you just don't know what
can happen and that's why it's so
important to live in a state that when
the bad stuff happens whether it's that
hurricane or it's a fire or an
earthquake or whatever it might be that
you're surrounded by people
that aren't going to completely crumble
at the exact same time there has been no
looting in Florida really think about
that I have not seen one reported event
of looting in Florida there are cities
and towns that are basically wiped out
people need food they need water it's
dangerous to be outside because power
lens and all that stuff why aren't we
seeing people ransacking Target and
burning down Pep Boys and all of those
things it's because the spirit of hey we
believe in Law and Order
we believe that
being a good citizen is valuable is is
worthwhile that's embedded in what's
going on here in Florida if you just
transferred what's happening in Florida
right now to some disaster in Cali you
know it would be the the people would be
would be behaving in a different way
that's why these things are all
connected that's why also a lot of the
answers are not purely political it's
also it's a spiritual answer meaning
like what do you believe so that when it
gets bad how will you behave and will
you live in a community of people that
behave in somewhat of a similar fashion
anyway we will keep talking about this
but we'll also get back to regular
politics and all the other stuff uh and
and then as I said uh baby two coming on
Thursday so it's going to be a crazy
week and then I also I'm gonna work I'm
talking to some of the people uh on the
ground here in Florida I want to do like
a week worth of shows when when Sanibel
when we can get just get on a boat
obviously the road's not going to be
rebuilt anytime soon but when we can
just get on a ferry or a boat if there's
electricity somewhere and we can figure
out an Internet situation or a starlink
or whatever it is and we'll just do some
shows from there and I'll see how I can
help out otherwise uh my full interview
with balash Orban who is the political
director to Hungarian prime minister
Victor Orban is up across platforms
right now oh and we have a cold close
for you today we almost use this at the
beginning but yesterday ladles and
Jelly's moons was the one year
anniversary of the let's go Brandon meme
it was the one year anniversary of this
wonderful moment in NASCAR when the
crowd was chanting thing something but
the reporter heard it slightly
differently and then the meme of the
meme of memes the meme of the Year came
out so we will end uh in honor of
Brandon see you tomorrow oh my God it's
just such an unbelievable moment Brandon
you also told me as you can hear the
chance from the the crowd
let's go Brandon Brandon you told me you
were gonna kind of hang back those first
two stages and just watch and learn what
did you learn that helped you there in
those closing laps oh my God it was uh
yeah I hope you guys have a wonderful
Christmas as well uh for Christmas and
let's go Brandon let's go Brandon I
agree hey by the way where are you in
Oregon
where's your home